ich habe bei mir ist noch spannend weil
ich über die stadtwerke eigentlich einen
langfristigen vertrag habe und wer aber
alle nicht wissen ob der halten wird
oder ob die stadtwerke noch ein
schlupfloch finden um auch langfristige
verträge zu killen das heißt im moment
im moment geht es noch aber das ist ja
die ausnahme also um dich herum kenne
ich nur menschen wo es sich erhöht hat
wo es sich auch dramatisch erhöht hat
ich denke wir müssen wir müssen eher wie
sagen in meinen augen ein bisschen wir
trennen zwischen dem was kurzfristig
getan werden muss um die menschen über
den winter zu bekommen die überhaupt
nichts dafür können für das was gerade
passiert
was mir aber viel wichtiger wäre ist
eine langfristige perspektive weil es
gibt ja viele leute die sagen ja gut
irgendwie das kriegen wir jetzt hin das
nächste halbe jahr aber was ist dann
wenn das der preis bleiben soll das geht
nicht und es geht ihm ganz und gar nicht
und da fehlt mir eben deswegen sage ich
wir brauchen endlich eine grüne
kernschmelze weil das was die was die
grünen wir müssen wir müssen die
bundespolizei und ja wir müssen sie
runter aber immerhin das problem ist es
gehört eigentlich hier rein weil wir
reden so zu sagen wir reden eigentlich
immer am thema vorbei wir brauchen eine
ganz eigene autarke energieversorgung
auch für deutschland und wir haben zehn
jahre lang haben die politiker sich
selber belogen und erfolg auch in dem es
hieß wir könnten aus der atomkraft
aussteigen wir könnten dieses land mit
windrädern und solardächer
bewirtschaften und jetzt haben wir das
problem dass heißt nicht einmal die
abhängigkeit von freundlichen nachbarn
ihrer these ein wir haben
nämlich genau rein weil das einfach das
problem ist doch dass wir dass wir keine
realistischeren ausweg haben weil wir
gesperrt werden von einer grünen politik
die sich nicht eingestehen will dass ihr
gründungsmythos wir steigen aus der
atomkraft aus dass der sich erledigt hat
und dass wir nicht aussteigen sondern 20
atomkraftwerke bauen
jetzt haben wir einen grünen
wirtschaftsminister der aus
wahltaktischen gründen sogar ein
kraftwerk irgendwie jetzt sofort
irgendwie unternehmen wie irgendwie und
man will partout nicht aussprechen nicht
einmal die 3 die wir haben will man uns
lassen und das sind einfach dinge wir
riskieren hier gerade den wohlstand in
miami das sind ja hellseherisch das
nicht schon wussten wenn wir gerade
einfach vor können die grünen nicht
einsehen wollen ein nein
gefühl ich muss da scheint man muss
unterscheiden wo wird man hin in fünf
bis zehn jahren da haben sie recht ich
bin auch immer für kernkraft gewesen so
dass du eine punkte an und jahre ist nur
haben
also da merkte die nicht funktionieren
und und die für der breite schichten der
bevölkerung und für breite schichten der
wirtschaft zu gänzlich unakzeptable
zuständen führen mit dem verlust von
arbeitsplätzen und so weiter und dies
müssen wir
kurzfristig durchaus teilweise der
britische weg jetzt unter tunnel durch
einen durch eine durch eine preisbindung
die dazu führt dass die dass die
der preisspitzen abgeschnitten werden
und für die muss der staat sind wir
nicht mehr darf ich nur raten dennoch
einsatz insgesamt ist die
augenblickliche lage kostet die
deutschland was jetzt was jetzt
energieimporte angeht 100 milliarden
euro mehr als vor einem jahr jetzt auf
jahresbasis gerechnet wenn wir jetzt von
diesen 100 milliarden mehrkosten 50
milliarden dafür auf wenn aus
staatskassen dass das dem mittelstand
das den normalverbrauchern bei ihren bei
ihren energierechnung dem team geholfen
wird dass die rechnen dass die nicht ins
um gemessene steigen dann ist das gut an
hat vgl dann ist das gut angelegtes geld
denn der muss kein entwickler also frage
einlangen liebe aber ich muss eine
rückfrage zu herrschen und zwar es wird
jetzt immer bevor jetzt die atomkraft
als das allheilmittel dargestellt wird
und form ukraine krieg waren wir so toll
was energie betrifft oder vor frau
merkel wir hatten ja noch nie ein
wettbewerbsvorteil in deutschland was
energie betrifft also es ist ja wieso
nur in ostdeutschland das war ja von
merkel das waren damals auch weder was
energie noch was drin aber können wir
nur den beginn machen
die anhängliche periode bamberg
wir hatten noch nie ein
wettbewerbsvorteil wenn die jetzt sagen
mit der atomkraft jedesmal atomkraft das
ist ja ein märchen dass das preis
günstig wäre es ist ja ein märchen es
ist ja auch teuer und mit der atomkraft
machen wir uns ja auch abhängig das ist
ja keine komplett unabhängige wähler
aber doch mal die dicke drin ja noch bei
der anderen sache denn denn das was ich
als problem sie ist dass das also dass
also viele mittelständische unternehmen
märkte verlieren als die schwierigkeiten
haben wenn wir diese breite zahlen
müssen und zwar in den nächsten in den
nächsten anderthalb bis zwei jahren und
das ähnlich geht für viele verbraucher
und wir würden die soziale situation
entspannen bei den verbrauchern und wir
würden die wirtschaftliche situation
entspannen bei den unternehmen
denn der wenn der staat sagt ich bin
jetzt hier ein gewisser preis garant und
wir führen mal die der preis auf sich
die wir ja immer schon früher hatten wir
mal wieder in
einem gewissen umfang ein und dann
könnte ich die politik in ruhe darüber
streiten ob sie die der langfristigen
energie lücken durch durch 30.000
windräder ausfüllt oder ob sie oder ob
sie lng aus katar holt oder ob ihm was
völlig neues einfällt oder opfer doch
darüber kann sich die polit oder hole
ende streiten aber erstmal muss die
wirtschaft und müssen die verbraucher
den gewissen werde sicher sein ich habe
dieser gegen behauptet dass hierbei war
dass preisgünstige energien wir konnten
und sogar war wir waren haben teurere
energie leisten aber irgendwo muss ja
mal eine grenze zu sein für die wahl in
der milch bei dem preiskonzept ich
gehe teilweise mit einem preiskonzept
erleben wird sich freuen da wird sich
freuen ja ich finde für den liberalen
wirtschaftsminister den wir haben wird
er sich besonders freuen wenn das denn
nicht an berlin heißt auch
finanziell leider finde die
entschuldigung herr lindner als
finanzminister wird sich freuen als
liberaler finanzminister ständig
staatsbeihilfen zu geben aber mein
eigentlicher punktes wir haben doch zwei
möglichkeiten das zu lösen sie reden von
den rentnerinnen und allen bürgern die
betroffen sind ich bin die erste die
dabei ist dass das was auf uns zu kommt
wahrscheinlich noch keiner richtig
ermessen kann noch keiner ja wir wissen
nicht was passiert wir wissen noch nicht
mal ob dieser konflikt entlastet wir
wissen noch nicht mal ob donatoren
diesen konflikt wir wissen nicht ob es
drei darf jemand lauert ihr wissen und
fliegt aber da gehen wir zu
je länger
der konflikt dauert desto mehr wird
diese soziale energiepolitische krise
sich zuspitzen und wir wissen nicht wie
die bevölkerung reagiert und ich rede
nicht nur von deutschland sondern auch
in frankreich italien wird und wie die
anderen und die einzige frage ist doch
wollen wir eine politik akzeptieren die
langfristigen das sehen wir doch jetzt
alle wirtschaftlichen basis daten gehen
darauf hinaus dass wir eigentlich eine
deindustrialisierung hier am start haben
ihre industrie machen schon zugehen wenn
die türkei gehen in den osten das kann
doch ein land wie deutschland
während der 31
auch an perspektive dass wir sagen wir
halten das jetzt irgendwie sechs monate
durch weil niemand weiß was er in sechs
monaten ist sondern dass wir sagen wir
hätten ja vielleicht noch eine andere
lösung wir gucken uns mal an die kommen
wie man aus wie kraus über verhandlungen
und mit einer realpolitischen
ökologen daran der ökonom sacha verna
andere wünsche ich habe ja schon bereits
ins nach der russland hat seine letzte
karte ausgespielt indem es einfach gas
lieferungen eingestellt hat mehr als ein
stellen geht nicht wir werden uns in
einem jahr eingestellt haben auf einen
auf eine auf eine energiepolitik ohne
russisches öl und ohne russisches gas
und da sind wir auch schon zur hälfte
durch und diesen punkt müssen wir kann
sich antrag können wir den ganzen können
wir die ganzen russland konflikt voll
von der energieabteilung können wir
schon wir fragen doch jetzt einmal jan
schäfer dienstag jetzt entsetzlicher nun
hab ich glaube auch das muss man jetzt
einmal also wir sind ja jeder darf er
seine these mitbringen und deswegen ist
es toll dass sie ihre auch dabei und
frau kelly ging es so wie ich sie
verstanden habe ja vor allem um die
frage wie organisieren wir eigentlich
für dieses land das ja einen immer
stärkeren strombedarf hat mit sicht auf
die nächsten jahre wissen von
stahlherstellern die sagen wenn sie grün
stahl erzeugen dann brauchen sie mit
sicht auf die nächsten 17 jahre das
fünffache an strom beispielsweise bei
sie haben das thema chemie gesagt also
unser stromhunger wächst und wächst und
hacks und ich glaube das was sie ja
sagen wollten war ja eigentlich die
frage
wie befriedigen wir eigentlich diesen
stromhunger machen wir das in dem wir
wunderland zukleistern mit windrad
absagen in solaranlagen die besonders
gut im winter funk zu ärgern oder machen
wir das beispielsweise auch mit co2 und
darüber reden wir reden über einmal über
die frage natürlich kosten das rita wenn
ich das immer richtig verstanden habe
ging es vor allem darum das co2 nicht
aus der luft zu bekommen aber deutlich
weniger co2 zu produzieren so habe ich
die grünen verstanden so wie ich auch
die spd mal verstanden viele andere
umweltschützer das mag alles gut und
richtig sein wenn dem so ist dann glaube
ich dann kommt frau keller auch ins
spiel mit ihren kernkraftwerken dann ist
auch eine nahezu co2 neutrale produktion
von energie erstmal ein segen und dann
kann man muss man die kostenfrage
stellen das ist vollkommen richtig
die sicherheitsfrage muss man auch
stellen aber dann sind wir bei den
proben tage ist ja so lange es keine
speicher für sonne und solar also
solarenergie und windanlagen gibt dass
wir das was wir im sommer beispielsweise
produzieren im winter drauf nutzen
können was ja toll wäre solange es dass
ich gibt brauchen wir andere
energieträgern und da kommt die kernrate
habe hat er sogar ein kinderbuch über
black als geschrieben frau keller ist es
vielleicht entfeuchter der grünen lakers
kommt mit interessanten arien was wir
kindern erzählt fragen die haben sich
manchmal stellt er gut also wir sagen
wir wir haben ja offen bei den grünen
leute die davon träumen dass wir
tatsächlich diese
deindustrialisierung vorantreiben die
sagen wachstum ist schlecht wir müssen
runter fahren wir müssen im prinzip
sozusagen wieder zurück in die höhlen
ich glaube dann sind sie zufrieden
irgendwie wenn wir das nächste
kinderbuch machen in die wie kleine lara
in der höhle sitzt mit ihrer kerze aber
der rest wird man dann das weiterleben
und mir fehlt eben tatsächlich hier
dieses eingeständnis auch der grünen das
ja auch völlig an der zeit vorbei ist
also auch europa auf europäischer ebene
das läuft jetzt ist jetzt quasi sogar
als grüne als grüne energie eingestuft
worden da sind sie kurz durchgedreht
weil sie es einfach nicht wahrhaben
wollen also ich erlebe tatsächlich ein
land das einfach nicht über die seinen
eigenen schatten springen will weil
dieses atomkraft nein danke ist
irgendwie so verankert und das soll dass
das alles gefährlich ist dabei haben wir
die wir sind niemals aus der atomkraft
ausgestiegen und das ist einfach eine
lüge ich finde es ist an der zeit den
menschen die wahrheit zu sagen wir sind
nie ausgestiegen wir haben den atomstrom
anschließend gekauft von schlechteren
und unsicheren volker jacken aus
frankreich aus tschechien wir haben bei
den nachbarn an gekauft wären wir
wirklich vor zehn jahren aus der
atomkraft ausgestiegen hätten wir vor
zehn jahren das desaster von heute mit
den kreisen schon gehabt und dann hätten
die leute realistisch gesehen was es
wirklich kostet aus der atomkraft
auszusteigen und dann wird er wie ein
junger krakaus aber auch nicht günstig
also dass es ein ja aber der rest der
welt also wie soll ich sagen natürlich
irgendwie können sie auch atomstrom
nicht kostenlos produzieren ich sage nur
wir werden aber wir werden viel mehr
strom brauchen sie sagen dass noch viel
mehr als jetzt und in dieser situation
mit einer regierung konfrontiert zu sein
die allen ernstes mitten in dieser krise
sich nicht durchringen kann auch nur die
letzten drei weiterlaufen zu lassen das
ist einfach nicht mehr erklären
freiwillig für das 80-fache ironie der
geschichte ist der frau keller das
robert habeck inständig darauf hofft
dass in frankreich die kernkraftwerke
die jetzt weiter laufen wir gehen ja das
ist ja hier hofft auf match das so geht
das nimmt einer dreier ein und will dass
die französischen kernkraftwerke die ein
anderer sicherheitsstandard haben als
sie deutschen will dass die laufen um
die drei meiler abzuschalten so dass ihr
wieder appetit
wenn ich bei einer solchen politik die
einfach hochgradig schizophren lasten
aus der wir besser man aussteigen das
ist ja mein plädoyer hier gewesen